set at the confluence of the Mekong and
nam khan rivers the port town of Luang
Prabang in northern Laos is an
exceptional combination of natural
splendor and abundant spiritual
traditions
[Music]
the town was designated a World Heritage
Site in 1995 for its unique blend of
traditional Lao and European colonial
influences from the 14th to 16th century
Luang Prabang was the capital of the
Lang CN Kingdom as well as the center of
Buddhist worship in the region
dozens of Buddhist temples dot the
surrounding area and arguably the most
impressive of them all is watching tog
this 16th century temple with its
steeply sloping pagoda style roof and
walls richly embellished with carvings
and mosaics escaped destruction by the
Black Flag army when the town was sacked
in 1887 rise before dawn to witness the
tradition of cybot or morning alms where
devotees offer food to the procession of
Buddhist monks as they make their way
through the streets the vibrant culture
extends beyond religious traditions from
the colorful night market where vendors
Hauk handicrafts to the early morning
produce market to traditional dance
performances beyond the bustling streets
live verdant mountains beckoning
visitors to explore the surrounding area
towering over the center of town mount
[ __ ] offers a breathtaking 360-degree
view of Luang Prabang as well as the
Mekong River Valley another must-see
destination is the coulomb see waterfall
a majestic triple tiered cascade that
spills into a series of pools which are
popular places for locals and tourists
to swim
[Music]
travel upstream from Luang Prabang to
the PACU caves which represent a unique
combination of the natural and the
sacred set into a limestone cliff the
two caverns are populated by thousands
of Buddha figurines brought by pilgrims
over hundreds of years
there's a reason Luang Prabang has drawn
a growing stream of visitors in recent
years it appeals equally to all types of
travelers
[Music]
[Music]